guys this is a premeditated scam this
guy is a piece of ever living
he is an absolute Scott what no one
talks about is how before liver King was
liver King he was a guy named Brian
Johnson and Brian Johnson didn't need
liver King to become rich because he was
already rich he was already selling
supplements long before he created this
liver King character and it made him
Millions upon millions of dollars from
it so what most people don't understand
about liver Kings before he was liver
King he was Brian Johnson an elite
Amazon marketer and so most of his
wealth like he's probably worth well
into the nine figures it came from
building this brand on Amazon ancestral
supplements by my estimates was very
close to a nine figure brand before
liver King existed it was only after he
became a multi-millionaire from his
ancestral supplements that he took that
money and used it to meticulously craft
perhaps the most perfect character that
was just guaranteed to go viral second
only to Andrew Tate so we should be
eating
eat more eating liver check this out
Godzilla
you get some liver
and this move this genius strategy
transformed him from a mere peasant
making only tens of millions of dollars
to making hundreds of millions of
dollars see typically influencers tried
to get famous first it's only after they
get their followers that they tried to
create a product to sell to Their
audience but liver King took this model
and flipped it on its head and it all
started with his supplement company it
all started with his first million and
his secret to making his first million
his secret to becoming a
multi-millionaire without any following
without any clout was by Gaming the
Amazon algorithm see a supplement
company ancestral supplements was
primarily based on Amazon first and just
like how YouTube has an algorithm that
you can learn master and manipulate
Amazon also has an algorithm that you
can gain and liver King exploited to
make millions he sat down and they
mapped out a character an amplified
character that was made for this short
form world right like you can tell if
you know branding it was all scripted
from the Barbarian workouts to the nine
ancestral tenants just the whole story
right he had bad Health he healed it all
I don't know the true inner workings but
anyone who knows digital marketing just
kind of had to take their hat off
because it was like super impressive and
in this video we're gonna put aside all
the influencer drama we're gonna put
aside the steroid drama and we're gonna
expose all of this so you can learn to
do the same for entertainment purposes
only don't do anything illegal with the
help of my good friend the genius CEO
Rob he's found a seven multi-million
dollar e-commerce Brands many of which
started on Amazon one so he's an expert
at the Amazon algorithm and knows all
the tricks of the trade he really helped
out with this video and he's got a
YouTube channel of his own exposing
stuff like this that you should
definitely subscribe to with the link
below so stay dangerous and this is the
liver King model
[Music]
thank you
so the not ancestral tenants are these
forces that have nourished us and shaped
us to epigenetically express our highest
and most dominant form step one in the
liver King motto is you want to choose
your niche so five years ago Brian
Johnson is sitting in his apartment not
much to his name how is he gonna go step
by step from nothing all the way to
liver King who might be getting pretty
close to a billionaire so he comes up
with this idea of creating a lifestyle
business okay and so at the the very
floor Step Zero you have to be in tune
with your passions something you're
interested in something that that you
feel like you could live doing for a
long time and so for Brian it was
obvious he was very into this ancestral
movement right like the the sun exposure
the cold plunge all that stuff that's
the that's Step Zero that's the building
block Brian Johnson created a liver
supplement brand and became the liver
King because at his core he probably
does really believe in the stuff he's
promoting this dude probably really is
out there eating raw liver taking ice
baths and walking barefoot in the Sun
every morning like clockwork does he
really believe that doing all this will
get him this ripped of course not that's
why you use steroids but does he believe
that this is the right way to live maybe
putting aside the Stars he does seem
genuinely passionate about this stuff
any you probably realize that this Niche
would be a great marketing play and if
you're gonna try to build a brand that's
gonna make you Millions you're gonna
need to choose something that you really
believe in too yeah and so I believe I'm
setting out on this you should pick
something that's conducive to your
lifestyle right however you live the
product that you choose to do should fit
into that lifestyle you can talk about
it more naturally you know when you're
talking like sales copy and that sort of
thing it just flows and so for liver
King anyone that's followed him knows
he's all about the nine tenets of
ancestral living and I believe eating
you know liver is like at the top of
that I don't know it's that specifically
but that's where this first product came
from right he knows how to Market it and
he has the story behind beef liver it's
rich in all these vitamins he's able to
put this marketing pitch together and
you know tell the story and like for me
genius was no different right like my
motto is optimize everything and so each
product was just a play on you know
optimizing Mind Body freaking Soul right
and you just live it it becomes part of
who you are okay so if someone wanted to
go into this and do something similar to
like what liver King has done they
should pick something that they're you
know actually passionate about like and
this doesn't have to be supplements but
let's say let's say Jake Tran wants to
do something that he'd be excited about
um dude like like start a Muay Thai
brand right like okay you don't like the
the shin guards you're using so there's
got to be some way to improve upon it
and obviously I want to send you down
this this rabbit hole but like
theoretically right it's like if you're
gonna one flag to build an Amazon
business on it would be something like
that because you're gonna train for the
next you know half decade and you're
gonna have Fighters and relationships in
that world and it just makes sense so
you just launched alphagraph what was
like the thought process behind that
like how did you pick the niche of
nootropic coffee yeah absolutely it's a
great question
um so I mean I had this existing coffee
brand because I'm I am a coffee
connoisseur right like I like coffee and
so as we've seen this masculinity
movement I'll just call it that like
continue to progress I said hey that's
the area I want to play in right like
I've trained martial arts my whole life
I eat healthy I'm raising a family blah
blah blah and so it's like it'd be fun
to start you know maneuvering in this
fast-growing segment a lot of the time
it doesn't have to be like a specific
product popularization as much as it is
a a broader movement you can see those
coming on social media right
um and so I I just kind of sat down at
the drawing board and I was like all
right well what can we do
you know from a coffee perspective that
allows us to participate in this Arena
and that's where the idea of alpha grind
you know came to be obviously the name
Alpha and then grind is it ties into the
brand but it was to you know solve like
this entrepreneurial need is for the the
hyper performers the people that want to
you know like it's achieve maximum
everything all day yeah so basically you
saw this movement this trend of like the
Andrew tank stuff whatever you want to
call it and you you're also passionate
about coffee
and you have experience in the new
traffic space obviously very successful
so you basically just like combined all
of that
correct I just brought it all together
in a way that makes sense and is were
there new Tropic coffees before
nothing of substance and I've positioned
it more you know it has like these
natural testosterone supporting
ingredients so I can kind of lean into
the whole like this is a male specific
thing
um which is again popular right now but
uh no nothing like this has really been
done but if you zoom out you look at the
coffee Market you go okay how many
people drink coffee how many people take
supplements it's like okay so clearly
there's the potential to reach people
there so then how do you do that and
scale and that's where the Amazon model
comes into play
[Music]
[Applause]
step number two creating your products
okay now step you've heard of this
Amazon thing you you know some people
who are making money on there you
realize that it's relatively uh overhead
light right use Amazon's Warehouse to
fulfill
um they have a huge customer base of 300
plus million Shoppers so what product
are you gonna sell on there how are you
going to create a brand and so this is
the step where you kind of have to sit
down and you have to find something that
has good margin can be commercialized
can be manufactured in a in a you know
reasonable quantity and then you have to
actually get it made you have to create
your brand once you've chosen your Niche
and you've identified your audience you
need to create a product to sell and it
doesn't have to be in a product category
that already exists before liver King's
ancestral supplements practically no one
was selling beef liver supplements
online liver supplements definitely
weren't a popular thing when you started
the product just has to be something
that you can easily manufacture and sell
for our profits you can popularize
pretty much anything on Amazon like what
do you mean by popular rice
like beef liver wasn't a thing
and you get Amazon to introduce beef
liver they have a they have a
Marketplace
they have a customer base of 310 million
people
310 million people that are ready to buy
and so if you can get Amazon to say hey
my product's really cool this is a good
product I need to show it to more people
you can popularize a thing you can make
some you know something that wasn't cool
yesterday all of a sudden be really cool
it's like how do we learn about new
things it's like okay if something's at
Costco you'll probably give it a shot or
if something's at a shelf talker at
Whole Foods it becomes relevant right
like if you see like apple cider vinegar
gummies that's an interesting one that
that exists now and it didn't five years
ago but it was it exists because it's
everywhere so many people see it and so
that's the basic formula on Amazon you
can take something that's relatively
unknown and if you do it right
like hundreds of thousands of people
will see it and try it
like
um liver King should you go after like
some product Niche that isn't a thing
yet or should you like go into like one
that's already has like popularity or I
I think the competitive Advantage
nowadays on Amazon is just doing
something unique and it can be
relatively known
but some unique spin right like you're
not gonna put another beef liver pill up
there
and do well right there's already 50 of
them now this that's not the game play
my like my mushroom coffee is a great
example that was relatively new we were
second in that space and in our
differentiation was using a U.S grown
mushroom and then Alpha grinds like
totally different no one's searching
testosterone boosting coffee no one's
searching nootropic coffee but again by
executing a launch properly
well we're introducing this new idea as
a potential staple to hundreds of
thousands of people through the Amazon
algorithm however it does really help if
you can hop on some kind of trend that
is really taking off for example ice
baths have really taken off over the
past few years so maybe you want to
create a new product in that Niche if
that's what you're into once you know
what you want to sell it's as easy as
finding the right manufacturer to
produce it getting an actual product
made nowadays is like way more easy than
anyone thinks
um if you Google like supplement
contract manufacturer or baby wipe
contract manufacturer pretty much
anything contract manufacturer they want
to find you you'll immediately get a you
know list of at least 10 different
suppliers you want to take a lot of time
to get The Branding packaging and
labeling right for your products on the
design and branding side again there's a
huge ecosystem built out in this world
now upwork Fiverr behance is probably my
favorite and you just go through and you
reach out to a designer you give them
some you know just a little Direction on
what it is you're trying to communicate
you get a brand made just like that
nowadays then you want to reach out to a
manufacturer most manufacturers have
completely TurnKey Solutions so you
really don't have to lift a finger to
get your product made just tell them
exactly what you want agree on pricing
and quantities order the smallest amount
of inventory that they allow and boom
you have your first batch of whatever
you're gonna sell you can now pay for a
professional seller account on Amazon
that costs less than forty dollars a
month have your inventory shift from the
manufacturer to the Amazon fulfillment
center Amazon would then dispatch it to
their warehouses all over the country
and voila you now have your product
ready to be displayed in front of
Amazon's 310 million customers all over
the world all you got to do is press the
launch button and take it live but wait
wait wait not so fast you are in the
home stretch but the journey is far from
over yet once your product is ready to
be listed on Amazon that is where the
hard part starts that's where you have
just 90 days to win or lose if you win
you can make tens of Millions for years
to come if you lose your product will
end up being buried in Amazon's search
results and all of this whether you make
millions or crash and burn all depends
on just one thing your launch so Brian
goes to this manufacturer he orders his
first thousand units he studies Amazon
he realizes to succeed on Amazon you
need reviews and you need a way to rank
at the top right you need to be pushed
out by their recommendation engine you
need eyeballs
[Applause]
at the end of the day any platform
whether it be YouTube or Amazon they
just care about one thing money for
YouTube to make a lot of money they need
to keep users on the platform for as
long as possible the longer the viewer
stays the more as they see and the more
money you to mix so the YouTube
algorithm rewards click-through rate and
watch time because those things mean
people are staying longer but for Amazon
to make money instead of trying to get
users to stay on Amazon longer the main
thing they care about is getting people
to spend as much money as possible every
time they visit Amazon and to optimize
for that the Amazon algorithm cares
about a few different things that if you
learn you too can game the algorithm so
from my understanding is uh you know
Amazon has an algorithm just like how
YouTube has an algorithm the YouTube
algorithm
Instagram has an algorithm Tick Tock has
algorithm absolutely so Amazon has some
kind of algorithm
to determine what products to promote
what products show up at the top of
search results what products show up on
the home page that's right is that so is
this algorithm Amazon algorithm like
gameable
the the whole point of what professional
Amazon sellers do is to is to game the
algorithm just just like just like how
you would you would game the YouTube
algorithm um so so on YouTube the
YouTube algorithm has a few levers you
can pull the main ones are click the
rate and watch time if you can optimize
like the title thumbnail and get people
to watch the entire video and stay on
the platform then YouTube will promote
the video more and it will eventually go
viral so what are the levers to pull on
Amazon yeah absolutely absolutely so so
I mean much like YouTube at the very top
of the funnel here it is it is
click-through rate that's why you see
people put a lot of focus on uh you know
the hero image if you look at Alpha
grind we have a little viral on Tick
Tock thing there it greatly helps click
through conversion conversion's an
obvious one but Amazon wants to show the
highest converting products because
again their intention is to maximize
customer dollars spent with every
customer visit to the website uh one of
the the lesser-known things is actually
uh we call like average order value and
so you know the more expensive your
product is or if people buy multiple it
again ties back into that idea of Amazon
you know Amazon wanting the customer to
spend as much money as possible every
time they visit Amazon so if you're an
Amazon Seller and you launch a new
product right and Amazon has no history
on it well you're going to want to make
sure that conversion rate is really high
you're going to want to make sure that
click-through rate's really high you're
going to want to make it so you know
customers look at other stuff don't buy
it and buy your stuff maybe they buy two
and so these are a lot of the levers
that during that 90-day period you are
needing to pull as a professional Amazon
Seller okay and so that's where this
launch list comes into play you can't
just throw a product out there and hope
it has Elite conversion as a matter of
fact it surely won't because you don't
have any reviews yet a lot of people
think reviews are what like Drive is
ranking and that sort of thing but
reviews have no impact on your ranking
they have a ton of impact on your
conversion and so as we move into this
90-day period you have a new product
with no reviews no one's seeing it no
one's even going to click through
because it's buried and so how do you
jump start this process
and get the conversion up get your
reviews and then getting it in that
Amazon recommendation engine and this is
where a launch list comes into play
[Applause]
see in the eyes of the Amazon algorithm
you're a new seller with a new product
that they have no data on so why on
Earth would they risk their virtual
shelf space on a new product that they
don't know for sure is going to sell
when there's a ton of other products
that they do have data on so what you
need is to be able to trigger the
algorithm with some sales you need to
show the algorithm that yes there is
demand for this product and yes if you
promote it Amazon is gonna make money
but in order to get sales you need to
trigger the algorithm but in order to
trigger by hour loan you need sales do
you see the chicken and egg problem we
have here to solve this dilemma we need
to use what's called a launch list so a
launch list is more or less a list that
you've built of people that you can
count on to buy your product now what
this means varies right maybe you're
maybe your super popular liver king and
you just post about a product on
Instagram everyone goes and buys and so
you've maintained a level of uh
conversion that Amazon really likes but
maybe you're not lubricant maybe you're
just sitting in your mom's apartment or
whatever right like when when he started
this Brian Johnson and you need to make
sure people buy it and you need to make
sure they review and so more times than
not what you'll see is you'll see
sellers build uh groups and I said
Facebook groups earlier because that's
where you can instantaneously interact
with people and what you see a lot
Amazon's clamped down on this a ton they
have all these ways of policing it but
you'll reimburse people to buy your
product just to guarantee that
conversion just to guarantee those
initial sales okay yeah this this is the
the popular method right so you have a
list of a thousand people you're gonna
give away a thousand bottles or if your
list is is if you only ordered a
thousand maybe your list is only a
hundred people but you're going to give
away a hundred units right they're gonna
PayPal them or you're gonna venmo them
and they're gonna go buy your product
and this creates conversion this gets
you your initial 100 reviews this jump
starts the Amazon recommendation
marketing machine
okay that makes sense so basically like
on YouTube for brand new channels on
YouTube you have to meet meet like a
higher standard to prove that your video
is worth recommending so I think it's
like easier for a big channel to get the
YouTube algorithm to recommend their
videos versus a brand new channel
because YouTube doesn't trust this
channel yet there's no history involved
with the channel they don't know how
good it is so sorry for new YouTube
channels you have to meet a higher
standard to go viral so on Amazon it's
kind of the same thing where if you
launch a brand new product you know
Amazon doesn't know if they can trust it
yet there's no history there's no buying
history so you have to meet like a
higher standard for uh to trigger the
Amazon algorithm to actually recommend
it is that correct that's absolutely
right think about how easy it is for an
established brand to launch a new
product they already have that Halo they
already have that awareness but yeah
you're absolutely right okay and the way
you do that on Amazon like the easiest
way is to create this launch list where
it can be like I'm assuming it can be
like a Facebook group or an email list
or a Discord or what whatever okay and
then once you have the launch list you
reimburse people to get them to buy the
products
uh and leave a review I'm assuming right
that's right this is against Amazon's
terms of service and so I would never do
such a thing but this is a a practice
that's largely done by most professional
Amazon sellers okay interesting so this
launch list like why what what would be
the incentive for someone to join your
launch list like why would they join
this random Facebook group well
first of all they get free product and
so that's why again being in an area
that I think you could speak to and that
you care about is important right like
like you go to your gym every day and
you there's probably 20 people that you
train Muay Thai with on a regular basis
that starts to build the basis of your
launch list maybe they have some people
right maybe you start and it's like it
just needs to be in a sector where you
know what you're talking about you know
what you're doing okay so how do you get
the first few people like is it people
in real life that you know or oh yeah
yeah I mean I mean like if you're
starting from absolutely nothing this is
day one your first 50 people should be
people that you've like personally met
okay and uh you get them in the group
then what you do you like make a post or
yeah you get them in the group or or you
just straight up hustle like you know
there used to be all these cool ways to
like automate and do all these things
but Amazon got really aggressive and so
uh they they recognize patterns and so
what most people do is like it's just a
straight up hustle for the 90 days like
you're you're texting the launch list is
conceptual and so maybe you get you know
people from social that you've never met
you put them in a Facebook group and
then it's a DM sort of thing but maybe
your first 50 people that you know in
real life it's like a text and you're
like hey man like this is my new new
brand I'd love for you to try this is
how it works I need Amazon reviews I
need
you know conversion and that's typically
how it works so I'll pay you
whatever the price is I'll send it to
you all you have to do is buy and leave
a review that's right can you do that
for me that's basically how it works
in a nutshell and like I said it's you
need people to do other actions nowadays
like that what we just described that's
like that's that would be like
Elementary and we we kind of have to get
up to high school nowadays okay how do
you get up to high school like asking
them to like hey click on this other
product then come back to my product and
then buy exactly exactly the couple
searches right like they have to it has
to look organic Amazon's AI is like
really good so you can't go right to it
and buy it and review it you can't have
all the reviews come at the same time
you can't have there's all these like
rules and hurdles to watch out for right
okay so basically Amazon has gotten
pretty good at recognizing yeah
recognizing if your manufacturing
reviews or purchases or whatever it's
their AI is
uh right there with Google and YouTube
okay so you literally tell people to
like hey
search open amazon.com search lists
maybe click on this phone first then go
back to mine then and then buy it and
then wait like three days and leave a
review
um is that kind of like the gist of it
like you literally tell people to do it
like that
take their phone if you have to and do
it yourself
okay I would never do this but
theoretically that's what works in the
Amazon algorithm
if you're Brian Johnson launching your
liver supplement brand for the first
time you probably had some kind of
launch list or launch strategy yeah I
have no doubt liver King had a core
launch list people that left phenomenal
reviews people that would do whatever he
said from an action perspective back
when he launched you could actually just
send people to the detail page
um so like it wasn't as sophisticated
back in 2017.
um but yeah I I have absolutely no doubt
that's how this brand was born
earlier you told me about how like you
saw some of his early ancestral
supplement reviews have like detailed
screenshots and images they uploaded so
when you think about that launch list
and conversion the top reviews on Amazon
really matter right if you if you one of
these products in particular it's a
great example of this it has some impact
on thinning hair right you take these
pills and and your thinning hair uh
restores it thickens again and so one of
his his products uh if you scroll down
you you see that top review it it is a
customer that's been taking this product
for 30 days and now their hair is super
thick again
to say about that is that is a very
loving customer you found there if you
know what I mean they must like really
love the product to like upload before
and after pictures and take the time to
do that right look and it's just it's
just the game right it's not I don't
want to ever throw anyone's uh business
under the bus I think he has an
incredible business I really do and I
think he cares about his products uh but
yeah yeah those uh
it's very interesting those customers
took so much time to to phrase something
we have no way of knowing if liver King
used these tactics or not and we're
definitely not recommending you do
anything illegal we're just saying that
these are popular tactics than most
professional Amazon sellers use and
again all of this has to happen within a
90-day period you need to show Amazon
that your product is getting organic
sales because if it's good enough to get
organic sales without the algorithm
recommending it then man the algorithm
should be recommending it why 90 days so
so the 90 day I think they call it the
honeymoon phase and that's just their
look back period And so Amazon the way
they kind of prioritize their ranking
and their their virtual shelf space is
based on a 90-day look back and they
always use that history to like position
you and so you know on one hand it's
beautiful if you if you do the launch
right you have yourself like a winner in
their machine indefinitely because the
look back is always showing more sales
unless you've got a stock that's the one
way to screw yourself if you fail the
launch then your 90 Day history says you
suck and I'll never show you to anyone
like that that is the
the game in a nutshell and so what do
you want to do during that 90-day period
you want to grab like you wanna you
wanna go like this organically naturally
like just just slowly up you can't come
out of the gate like this right that'll
that'll get you in some trouble and so
you just want to get to this this
equilibrium of
real customer uh conversion by the end
of the 90 days right you use your launch
list to jump start things at a certain
point Amazon starts showing you to more
people you actually need a good product
right like nowadays you you need a good
product and so you want to get to the
point where okay now you're actually
converting at a at a meaningful clip
with real customers and you you do this
throughout the 90-day period and you
have yourself a money making machine but
regardless of how liver King first got
off the ground he obviously eventually
headed out of the park and the great
thing is all it takes is one good
product one good launch and the rest of
your journey becomes a lot easier from
there you simply scale up your first
products and then you eventually want to
rinse and repeat this process for new
products underneath your same brand just
like what liver King did
[Music]
once liver King had his first supplement
successfully growing on Amazon he
eventually launched a second one
launching the second one was a little
bit easier but it was still tough but
then came the third one then the fourth
one then the fifth one with each launch
becoming a little bit easier to launch
than the last B flavor was the first one
I remember it had like 900 in a solid
five star reviews solid five is like
totally unheard of that's really hard to
pull off
uh you're talking about like 5.0 yeah
like like not 4.7 or whatever 5.0
okay
and so I he had that product as the hero
for a while and then they just slowly
started tagging on more and more
products I think now he probably has
like 20 or 30 different skus ranging
kind of all across the board but
um again just continued to play the
Amazon game right leverage the first SKU
had a bigger
brand following and just kept rinsing
and repeating okay so
once you have the first accessible
products and you launch another product
in your underneath the same brand like
ancestral supplements much easier it's
much easier and I'd say I'd say like
like two is still it's not like as easy
it's easier than one yeah but then one
for over like three or four now you can
have this brand Halo like people are you
know they're seeing you more you come
out with something new your existing
customers are more inclined to give you
a shot
um yeah liver King continues scaling
like this until he was at a point where
he was selling a ton of different
supplements on Amazon all under the
ancestral supplements brand but
eventually he hits the same glass
ceiling that every successful Amazon
Seller hits even though Amazon has a
massive customer base there's still a
limit to how much money you can make off
of a single brand in the case of
ancestral supplements there are only so
many customers on Amazon that would be
interested in buying these type of
supplements and Brian Johnson was
already
ethically all of them now don't get me
wrong he was still making life-changing
money we're talking tens of millions of
dollars or more but he was stuck his
Revenue wasn't growing as fast anymore
so Brian Johnson was left with a
decision and every Amazon Seller reaches
this inflection point I was there myself
you get to a point where you've gotten
all you can out of Amazon and it's
different for everyone right like genius
and nootropics was a x amount of
business his was a different size
business but you reached this point
where you go what am I going to do next
to progress this brand and I actually
went through this thought exercise and I
was ready to execute my own version of
it in a different way but how am I going
to succeed outside of Amazon right you
have the capital you have a brand making
seven or eight million dollars a year
how am I going to get to 15 million
dollars a year and that's where you kind
of look outward it's like okay how am I
going to win social media now right how
am I gonna like you know to roll out the
stores you need a social media presence
so so I mean it really just ties back to
how am I going to win social media we
could just keep it right there and I
went through the same thought exercise
and uh it requires a financial
commitment outside of your comfort zone
each brand needs to come up with a
unique strategy to win on social media
and so you know this is kind of the time
where most people go I don't want to
take the risk I don't want to take the
reward I'm making four or five million
bucks a year I can sell for five times
that 25 million in my pocket I'm done
and and I mean everyone I know has taken
that route I'm done route okay so what
do you mean by hitting a ceiling like is
there like a practical limit to how much
money you can make with a single brand
on Amazon is that what you're talking
about this it seems like it it seems
like it like you just you kind of reach
a point where maybe you don't know where
to go right like genius was a good
example we dominated nootropics there
was no more money to make in nootropics
okay
you can't just exhausted the marketplace
for that that's right most people would
have been content with the money he was
making most people would have been
perfectly fine selling the company for
an even bigger payday but for some
reason Brian Johnson wanted more Brian
Johnson wanted to get to the next level
he wasn't okay with tens of millions of
dollars he wanted hundreds of millions
maybe even a billion and traditionally
to get to that kind of level you would
have to come up with a very Grand very
expensive marketing strategy for your
brand outside of Amazon you would have
to run a ton of ancestral supplement ads
on social media for example but Brian
Johnson notice an interesting Trend the
Creator economy and influencer-led
Brands thank Mr beastburger and the like
Brian Johnson definitely wasn't an
influencer he didn't have a personal
brand at all but what he did have was a
proven product brand and what he also
had was the money to jump start a
personal brand of his own and it was in
that moment that Brian Johnson decided
to create the liver King liver King did
that thought exercise and he saw the
merging of tick tock and more of this
like uh
you know Creator based brand economy
kind of existing and his strategy was
like the inverse he decided he's gonna
attack social media as himself which I
think was brilliant and so yeah that's
kind of the you hit the ceiling on
Amazon what are we gonna do next to
propel the movement and that's where the
uh liver King character came to be and
the way he crafted this character the
way he executed on it was unlike
anything the world had ever seen before
foreign
[Applause]
he sat down and they mapped out a
character an amplified character that
was made for this short form world right
like you can tell if you know branding
it was all scripted from the Barbarian
workouts to the nine ancestral tenants
just the whole story right he had he had
bad Health he healed it all
and so that yeah he also did he also
referred to people as like Primal and
non-primals or whatever exactly exactly
how does like that that's the uh cult
terminology or yeah exactly yeah yeah
and so it was it was it was all scripted
and it was amazingly executed and so
what all went into that like I don't I
haven't you know pulled back the curtain
like I don't I don't know the true inner
workings but anyone who knows digital
marketing just kind of had to take their
hat off because it was like super
impressive but there was one problem
with this plan his physique didn't fit
the mold he wasn't jacked enough swole
enough to fit the character that he
crafted which is where the steroids came
in and for a while it worked insanely
well the liver king became one of the
most viral people on the planets in an
insanely short amount of time second
only to Andrew Tates and his business
exploded from wherever it was at proudly
in the low millions or tens of millions
to over a hundred million dollars a year
so you're right I do have three
companies that make 100 million dollars
a year and that ladies and gentlemen is
the power of a finely crafted personal
brand over a faceless brand with a
personal brand you have the possibility
to go viral way more and way faster than
you ever could with a faceless brand but
even though you can go up super fast all
it takes is one mistake one action that
doesn't look good in the eyes of the
public one slip up and that same general
public that propped you up on a pedestal
will gladly tear you down bits by bits
there's like 10K Egypt
those are implants do you think you
think somebody get a feeling and they
don't move liver King with the big GH
gut is on steroids come on this is dumb
man this is a uranicon game and you got
busted and it's unfortunate that you
feel terrible I'm sorry you feel bad
think about it there's a reason why
banks are faceless there's a reason why
banks are never based on a personal
brand there's a reason why if I ask you
to name me a CEO of a bank you would
maybe be able to name Jamie Diamond from
Chase but no one else it's because
personal brands are shaky fragile
they're a double-edged sword and liver
King is the prime example of nuts but
whatever your thoughts are on him he
proved that you really can't design
fabricate engineer think up an
influencer for nothing and turn that
influencer into a reality so expect many
more meticulously crafted characters to
take off in the future but again liver
king would have never been liver King if
Brian Johnson didn't make his first
Millions by understanding the Amazon
algorithm platforms like Amazon keep
their algorithms a closely guarded
Seeker for obvious reasons but
apparently a guy named real boss daddy
allegedly hypothetically got to see the
internal documents for Amazon's
algorithm firsthand don't ask me how and
he wrote down exactly how it works you
know before I was to have one of my
several hundred friends or vpns
purchased this product I would want you
know either these friends or these Bots
to type in many different keywords okay
keywords like mushroom supplement lines
main supplement uh nootropic supplement
brain supplement brain booster
supplement blah blah blah blah blah and
on each search click around bounce very
quickly off of competitor list don't
like them this is there's a compare
feature Amazon loves so like let's say
like click genius mushrooms and then
yeah and Just Bounce right off right
away why give them news a product yeah
yeah yeah exactly it's not necessarily
to bury the competition because that's
not that's just to yeah it's to make
yours look better in comparison watch
the full breakdown of the Amazon
algorithm on the gnceos channel by
clicking the card on the screen right
now or with the link below one good
trick Amazon you could not see that as a
nine figure seller who's built seven
different Amazon Brands I'm about to
take you into the underworld of Amazon
[Music]